tap I mean there was a lot of confusion
CU initially it was a go on you after
they initially credited you with the tap
back now it looks like Steph is getting
the game winner just you were down there
in the mix and obviously arguing with
what was going on what's your
perspective uh my perspective was that
my hand touched the rim uh cuz I was
going I was going to it looked like the
ball was about to pop out so I was going
to uh get a putb and when I jumped to
get the putback giddy like went back
into my leg so kind of brought my hand
down and hit the rim but hitting the rim
is not a Goten so I didn't affect the
shot and we won I also saw giddy had
pulled the net as well you know so it
was some confusion on and
um um sheay has said if he touched the
net and it didn't affect the ball it's
not a go 10 and she said if uh
if if I touched the rim and I didn't
affect the ball it wasn't the go 10 I
knew I didn't affect the ball so I
thought it was good and we got got the
bucket was saying that during the review
maybe not for you but it was emotional
in the Huddle just okay wait no we're
feeling good or wait no is it going to
go the other way I mean what was it like
what you knew in your head I didn't
affect the shot but waiting for one of
those uh I mean you you're kind of just
really at the mercy out of referees
though because I didn't believe I affect
the shot but I also didn't believe I was
a block file either um so you know
you're you're kind of at the mercy of
the refs and whatever call they decide
to make um and you know they decided
that it was a no call so take it